les etats-unis ont célébré ce vendredi
le premier anniversaire des accords
d'abraham conclu il ya tout juste un an
par le président donald trump ces
accords ont conduit à une normalisation
des relations entre israël et plusieurs
états arabes pour en parler on va
retrouver à washington notre
correspondant thomas gonnet siens
tomas bonjour alors pour l'occasion le
chef de la diplomatie américaine a tenu
une réunion virtuelle avec les
représentants des pays concernés
oui cinq représentants ont assisté à
cette réunion virtuelle des
représentants des états unis évidemment
du bahreïn des émirats arabes unis du
maroc et bien sûr d'israël un sommet un
virtuel pour d'une part célébrer le
travail effectué sur la normalisation
des relations entre israël et les pays
arabes et aussi pour lancer un appel à
d'autres pays d'autres représentants
pour qu'ils rejoignent aussi ces accords
d'abraham écouté les explications
d'anthony blinken
on nous encourageons davantage de pays à
suivre la voie des nra de bahreïn et du
maroc nous voulons élargir le cercle de
la diplomatie pacifique c'est dans
l'intérêt des pays de la région et du
monde qu israël doit être traité comme
tous les autres pays la normalisation
prévu à une plus grande stabilité à une
coopération accrue un développement
mutuel autant de choses dont la région
et le monde ont cruellement besoin en ce
moment à revenir à la conclusion de ces
accords ou ashington avait donné un
certain nombre de garanties aux états
arabes que ce soit était partenariat
économique ou dans le cas du maroc en
échange de la normalisation de ses
relations avec israël les etats-unis
reconnaissent la souveraineté du maroc
sur le sahara occidental reste
maintenant donc à convaincre d'autres
pays à rejoindre ces accords en premier
lieu desquels on pense évidemment à
l'arabie saoudite riyad entretient déjà
des relations stratégiques avec israël
mais le pays n'a donc pas signé ces
accords car il existe encore un certain
nombre d'oppositions notamment au sein
de la famille royale saoudienne alors
dans le même temps justement dubaï donne
il a approuvé un contrat militaire donc
entre les états unis et l'arabie
saoudite à thomas est ce qu'on peut dire
que le locataire de la maison blanche
est finalement dans la continuité de la
politique étrangère de donald trump
oui il paraît loin le temps de la
campagne présidentielle américaine ou
joe biden promettait de faire payer les
dirigeants saoudiens pour le meurtre du
journaliste kamal jamal khashoggi pardon
le président des états unis semble
finalement avoir privilégié les
relations économiques entre ryad et
washington en épargnant le prince
héritier de toute sanction sur ce
dossier comme sur de nombreux autres by
donne poursuit en fait la diplomatie de
son prédécesseur anthony blinken a
d'ailleurs salué lors de cette réunion
virtuelle le succès est d accord
d'abraham qui je vous le rappelle ont
été signés sous la présidence de donald
trump il ya maintenant un an et que ce
soit sur les dossiers du nucléaire
iranien sur le dossier cubain ou encore
sur le dossier de l'afghanistan est bien
l administration de joe biden poursuit
la même politique d'abord été menée par
l'administration précédente et sur le
fond elle malgré les annonces d'un
retour au multilatéralisme promis par
joe biden le président des états unis
est en fait encore bien ancré dans
l'amérique à first si chère à donald
trump et la faire des sous marins
français en est l'illustration parfaite
après avoir beaucoup critiqué la
diplomatie de l'ancien président
républicain on peut dire que la
différence d'à proches promise par joe
biden ne saute pas vraiment aux yeux
merci beaucoup à vous de m'abonner en
direct depuis washington